7e vidéo
je vais un peu calmé aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on va parler où vous avez vu dans le
titre un peu de mémoire
hier je vous ai laissé avec une petite
énigme simple j'ai pas encore regardé
les commentaires puisque la vidéo d'hier
est pas sorti pour moi un moment je te
parle
c'est très fatigant à cette mise en
abyme temporel la réponse était simple
les été classé comment alors ses
nombreux ces chiffres il était classé
par ordre alphabétique tout simplement
tu peux vérifier j'ai pas dis des
bêtises vous était juste vous par ordre
alphabétique et qui seraient rangés dans
un dictionnaire le moment de gênant donc
aujourd'hui je voulais juste vous parlez
d'un d'une piste de réflexion sur le
palais mental et la mémoire
on a souvent parlé sur la chaîne je me
d'ailleurs des petites vidéos ici vers
le palais mantel si vous n'avez pas fait
vous même le mind palace qui permet de
stocker des informations dans un lieu
qu'on a créé dans son esprit où a lieu
qu'on connaît qu'on a reproduit dans son
esprit il ya une piste d' idée que j'ai
eue mais je dois pas être le premier à
l'avoir je m'attribue pas du tout la
paternité tout algérien lui à ce sujet
là qui est intéressante j'utilise depuis
quelques temps et ça marche pas mal
c'est au lieu d'utiliser un lieu
d'utiliser son corps et je pense que ça
peut être pratique pour ceux qui ont du
mal à visualiser entièrement a le mieux
construit de toutes pièces ou ou dans
les débuts du palais mental c'est à dire
que je vais utiliser mon corps ma main
avec les cinq doigts par exemple pour
ranger 5 informations donc je vous
rappelle les bases du ballet mental
c'est que comme le cerveau fonctionne
par association il est complètement
associatif si j'ai une image et que je
l'associé à une autre image en fait je
ne mets krainer je ne crée pas de
nouvelles informations
j'associe juste deux choses existantes
dans ma mémoire lantern ensemble à une
connexion est bien là en normal vous
savez où est votre main gauche par
exemple c'est quelque chose que vous
connaissez vous avez toujours vécu avec
vous allez donc associer une information
à la main et visualiser cette
information dans votre main si possible
d'une manière originale créative et un
peu drôle ou décalés si par exemple la
formation c'est un gant un gant sur une
masse tellement logique que vous risquez
de l'oublier pour le et je vais voir
refaire tout le topo vraiment regarder
la vidéo sur le palais mental les vidéos
que j'ai fait sur le sujet si c'est
votre première fois sur ce délire là
sera plus simple pour vous à comprendre
mais pour polluer pour les un peu rodé
et chez le peuple d internet
et bien vous pouvez donc soit associé
des choses à chaque doigt ou à gramat
complète à chaque membre hockey en
surface mais aussi en intérieur on peut
être ai je peux très bien imaginer en
fait quelque chose à l'intérieur de ma
main associé aux eau associée aux
muscles associés aux organes
oui c'est un petit peu dégueulasse et un
petit peu le palais mental de dexter
cieux par là mais c'est très efficace
original et ça évite par exemple si vous
devez stocker quelque chose très
rapidement dans un nouveau palais mental
que vous avez le vôtre qui est déjà en
surstock ou en utilisation autre chose
que vous n'avez pas le temps de recréer
des pièces ou de ré imaginer un autre
lieu pour le faire vous pouvez faire
comme moi c'est à dire vous en servir
emballé mentale temporaire certains
plans de ces vidéos là je les ai stocké
sous forme d'imagés d'informations que
j'ai stocké dans un palais mentale top
horaire qui est composé de ce corps là
celui que vous pouvez vous initier à la
caméra ou alors je me suis dit c'était
une piste intéressante à partager avec
vous pour parler un peu de mémoire mais
comme on est au calendrier de l'avent
jusqu'au 24 décembre
et j'avais dit je vous présenterai
quelque chose à chaque vidéo tous les
jours à 6 heures jusqu'au 24 je vous
parle aujourd'hui
alors je vous reparle pour ceux qui ont
riche vous parle toujours à ses plans
pas le micro est toujours là je vous
reparle d'un jeu que j'avais dont
j'avais parlé sur un live sur la chaîne
c'est le jeu d'énigmes assassin's creed
ok vous avez voulu vous en parler parce
que j'avais trouvé ça original qu'ils
fassent ça et quand j'en avais parlé en
live
je voulais un peu mal vendu quand j'ai
lu dans les commentaires je me suis oui
ils ont raison parce que la seule chose
que je pouvais faire l'ied avec vous
c'était vouliez
certaines énigmes mais les énigmes elle
était beaucoup trop simple j'ai même
arrêté de les faire en live on est passé
à autre chose alors que le jeu est plus
intéressante ça mais tout l'intérêt du
jeu réside aux autres énigmes que vous
ne pouviez pas faire en live avec moi
parce que il ya des énigmes de codes
cachés par exemple il ya beaucoup de
code secret d'ailleurs je vous renvoie à
la vidéo que vous voyez sa fiche est
maintenant que j'ai fait il ya quelques
jours sur les codes secrets et
d'ailleurs est fournie ce petit cercle
de concordance extrêmement pratique est
fait en quart temps précieux
mais surtout quand vous jouez à
plusieurs voix la cia il n'y a pas que
les énigmes ya quand même beaucoup de
choses à faire leurs achats passés
cérébrale à on est sur un délire comme
ça sur on est quand même sur le principe
d'un jeu d'énigmes mais en forme de jeux
de société et là où je trouve qu'ils ont
été très très bon c'est que chacun
incarne un personnage secrètement
c'est un personnage issu d'assassin's
creed ya des templiers il ya des
assassins et chacun doit tuer quelqu'un
mais pour ça doit deviner qui est la
personne
donc là il ya des éléments dans le jeu
qui vous permettent de deviner qui est
qui
et ces personnes vous savez si vous
connaissez la licence d'assassin's creed
c'est à différentes époques
eh bien il va falloir aller à la bonne
époque son pouvoir tuer la personne et
pour aller à la bonne époque il faut
simplement répondre à une énigme de la
bonne époque puisque toutes les énigmes
aussi son temporisé je pense que c'était
extrêmement floue et en même temps c'est
à vous donner une idée des enjeux qui
sont un peu au delà des énigmes voilà
c'est un jeu de société d'énigmes tout
est assez original pour être souligné je
connais le prix je ne me souviens plus
d'un coût de 30 euros
ça vous de communes 30 bal fut pas ma
tasse tout au moins cher c'est cru quand
même 30 euros et je vous mets le lien
dans la description 30 euros c'est un
prix standard c'est quand même un peu
plus cher que l'une de mes classes pour
le l'interpol dont vous trouverez le
lien dans la description qui fait aussi
un excellent cadeau de noël ça c'est dit
c'est place et je te mets un pouce en
l'air très comme en mettant en retour tu
peux tu abonnés s'ils n'ont pas encore
fait et rendez vous demain à 6 heures du
matin et ce sera comme ça jusqu'au 24
décembre
parce que moi je suis pas comme un
chocolat je te fait pas grossir
oui
il
on